le Meetic smartphone a clapet de
Motorola et de retour c'est le Razer il
a une charnière en bulle d'eau on te
sent absolument pas de pliure et ça
c'est vachement ingénieux il a un grand
écran à l'intérieur de 6,7 pouces taux
de rafraîchissement de 144 Hertz il a
aussi un écran extérieur de 2,7 pouces
vous pouvez par exemple regarder YouTube
dessus une calculatrice vous pouvez
envoyer un message très facilement en
tapotant sur son petit clavier vous avez
accès à la météo à votre agenda mais il
sert également pour faire des photos
parce que vous avez un double module
photo de 50 et 13 mégapixels et on peut
même se voir ici directement sur l'écran
externe on peut faire de la vidéo
jusqu'en 8k on a beaucoup de
performances grâce au sein dragon 8 plus
gene one bref de l'innovation avec ce
Motorola Razer de 2022 dites-moi comment
vous le trouvez en commentaire et pour
plus d'infos sur la tech pensez à vous
abonner